difficulties and the need to
modernize our work
gave us a new impulse and a new character even in the
period of the fight against the pandemic of the
coronavirus infection, and we managed to do a lot even then,
from the point of view of updating this very
regulatory base
, getting rid of
archaic procedures that prevent us from moving
forward at the pace that is necessary in the
country.  сейчас When we were faced
with the need to solve
at a faster pace the issues related to the
provision of the special military
operation and
related to the struggle with the restrictions in the
economic sphere, which we
faced
without any involvement, unprecedented
Ukraine is breaking the so-called second army
of the world, and then Russia will only be asking for
something in Iran,
trying to squeeze something out of Western countries,
inventing various nonsense about Ukraine,
intimidating, deceiving, never again will
Russia be a subject that can dictate something to someone. It
no longer has the potential
to dictate the world, see it
Russian potential is being wasted now
on This is madness for a war against our
state and the entire free world. There was
no gas influence. There was no military influence. The
political weight is evaporating. Now the
isolation is constantly increasing. There were
ideological ambitions. Now there is only disgust and
this is a very important change in the configuration in
our part of Eurasia.
Russia will lose more of its potential now, all the more
realistically and freedom is gained by all peoples. And
next to Russia and within its borders, Ukraine,
first of all, on February 24 in the Kremlin,
they could not even think about it, although it was worth it, but
now on October 24, there is no longer such a
Russian official and propagandists
who would not understand where everything is going for them,
they long ago began to remember the
year 1917, the feeling of failure in Russia is getting
stronger, we still have to go the way to the
Ukrainian Victory, it is a difficult way
to go through this winter, which will be the most difficult in
our history, to do the necessary part of the
work in the fall, winter and spring  in order to have
the results required by the state, hold the
max  potential mobilization of our
partners for the sake of the struggle for freedom and
not allowing the
common enemy to split the global pro-
democratic coalition